for the first time the top
pharmaceutical executive was found
guilty in a case linked to the nation's
opioid crisis a federal jury convicted
iNSYS therapeutics founder john kapoor
and four other former executives of the
company yesterday prosecutors accused
them of bribing doctors to prescribe a
highly addictive fentanyl spray called
subsys and a Warner is here with what's
being called a landmark prosecution and
a good morning Brad good morning one
time billionaire john kapoor was once
one of the country's most powerful
pharmaceutical executives Thursday's
verdict is a sign of the government's
mounting efforts to hold drug makers and
distributors accountable for the
nationwide opioid crisis it took 15 days
for a federal jury in Boston to find
former iNSYS therapeutics chairman john
kapoor and four other former company
executives guilty as part of what
prosecutors described as a nationwide
conspiracy among the pieces of evidence
presented during the 10-week trial this
five-minute video promoting the fentanyl
spray substance featuring an incest
company salesman rapping about
prescribing higher drug doses using a
process known as titration
prosecutors say the video was just one
of the dubious tactics iNSYS used to
boost profits which also included
bribing doctors by paying them for sham
speaking engagements in 2017 CBS News
learned incest made 18,000 payments to
doctors in 2016
totaling more than two million dollars
this case had very good evidence Michael
Canty is a former federal prosecutor who
has advised states on suing opioid
companies I think that this will send a
message to other prosecutors that look
these are cases that can be brought if
you have the evidence and you can put it
before a jury there's hope that you can
get the you hold those criminally
responsible in a statement incest said
quote the actions of a select few former
employees are not indicative of the hard
work conducted by our talented team
today an attorney for John Kapur says
they'll continue to fight to clear his
name
while sentencing dates have not yet been
set racketeering charges carry up to 20
years in prison
Anthony Anna thanks